[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir ça va je suis bien là
parce que je me suis mis quand même la
pression pour être à la hauteur de vos
attentes ce soir est là comme d'habitude
quand je me montre au regard des autres
j'ai comme un doute
est ce que parce que je suis
suffisamment comme il faut et ce doute
en fait c'est un vernis c'est une petite
couche au dessus d'une peur une peur qui
est là depuis vraiment longtemps la peur
d'être critiqué jugé rejeté et de me
retrouver ici maintenant devant tout le
monde
seul seul au monde le revoilà au fil du
temps j'ai trouvé une source à cette
peur ma première journée d'école très
intéressante
je me souviens de plein de visages
inconnus qui me regardent un peu comme
maintenant
grosso modo puis je me souviens d'avoir
eu peur et puis d'avoir été triste comme
rien se passer j'ai piqué une grosse
crise de colère puis on m'a attrapé par
le fond de mon pantalon et on m'a mis en
dessous du robinet d'eau froide jusqu'à
ce que je me taise ce jour là j'ai
appris qu'être comme il faut c'est pas
montrer ses émotions en public
alors je me suis tu pendant 35 ans 35
ans passés dans mon mental à faire en
sorte qu aucune émotion ne dépasse
pendant ce temps là évidemment j'ai
capté commence à fonctionner à l'école
être comme il faut c'est être un bon
petit élève bien sage comme ça on a de
la tranquillité du respect inutile de
vous dire j'ai cartonné à l'école
primaire en fait c'était simple à la fin
j'étais premier de l'école et ce jour là
le jour où j'ai reçu mon bulletin me
souviens de m'être retrouvé dans la cour
de récréation avec un truc bizarre
j'aurais dû être fier et content j'étais
vie
complètement insatisfaits je me disais à
l'intérieur c'est bien d'être comme il
faut mais moi là dedans
bon c'était inconscient donc j'ai
continué et pendant mon adolescence
j'étais un gendre idéal gentil souriant
sympa j'essayais de faire en sorte
d'être comme je pensais que l'autre
attendait que je sois bref je portais
plein de masques et moi je pensais que
ça se voyait pas trop et ça a marché
jusqu'à ce qu'un de mes amis me disent
ben écoute c'est super tout le monde a
trouvé intelligent
c'est dommage il aurait aussi pu de
trouver sympa et la neige me suis dit
stop
qu'est ce qui était arrivé
comment en est elle arrivée à ne plus
oser montrer qui j'étais vraiment
être libre d'être moi la réponse tient
en trois mots soif de reconnaissance
alors voilà ça c'était une partie de mon
histoire mais j'aurais tout aussi bien
pu parler de vos histoires histoires
différentes même combat nous avons tous
soif de reconnaissance parce que nous
sommes des êtres humains
et ça dure comme ça depuis deux cent
mille ans prenons un homme et une femme
standard examinons les plus près pas de
crocs pas de griffes pas de venin dans
leur environnement naturel et que les
autres bêtes sauvages
aucun avantage compétitif sauf un leur
cerveau et c'est sur lui qu'ils ont misé
on peut pas gagner un combat à un contre
un pas de problème on va en organiser un
à dix contre un si l'être humain règne
sur la planète aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'il a été capable de développer une
collaboration comme nul autre
et pour collaborer il ya une étape
fondamentale importante et essentielle
faut se rendre compte qu'on est face à
un autre être humain
et puis foule lui faire savoir à travers
un si c'est ça la renaissance un signe
de reconnaissance
c'est d'unité des changes humain un
signe qu'on reconnaît que l'autre existe
et en plus
qu'il a de la valeur alors ils n'ont pas
tous la même valeur énergétique les
signes de reconnaissance
il y en a qui sont faibles comme un like
sur facebook ou un salut faible
reconnaissance y en a qui ont une grosse
valeur énergétique comme un compliment
un mot d'amour une accolade et puis en a
qui sont potentiellement destructeurs
comme une réprimande une remarque un
geste de rejet mais ça on va y revenir
pour l'instant on va rester dans un
monde idéal et dans ce monde idéal tout
le monde échange plein de signes de
reconnaissance positif et grandit en
énergie ça c'est l'effet waouh
comme dans war j'adore ce que tu fais
waouh c'est super comme tes fringues les
années inspire à fond waouh
vous êtes tous là ici ce soir ben moi ça
me touche merci alors pour ce qui est
génial dans cette histoire c'est que
c'est un nouvel ordre économique s'est
basé sur une économie d'abondance les
signes de reconnaissance sont gratuits
on peut en donner autant qu'on veut
quand on en reçoit on gagne de l'énergie
et on en perd pas quand on en donne
révolutionnaire alors pourquoi ne sommes
nous pas tous empli d'une super et belle
énergie positive parce que les signes de
reconnaissance qu'on reçoit il s'adresse
à notre masque social le masque social
c'est ce qu'on montre aux autres pour
est accepté il ya deux forces qui nous
pousse à trier un peu ce qu'on montre la
première celle envie de collaborer
dixit les hameaux sapiens la deuxième
c'est la peur la peur du rejet parce que
nous les êtres humains on a compris ça
il ya 7500 génération être rejetée c'est
un peu comme mourir prenez un enfant
homo sapiens entre 0 et 3 ans imaginez
que son clan labo donnent leurs efforts
pardon l'abandonnent seul dans la nature
aucune chance de survie c'est clair donc
pour un enfant être acceptée par son
clan c'est pas un luxe
c'est une obligation c'est une nécessité
il doit être reconnu et à partir de là
ils existent
et en plus il a une place sur cette
terre alors dans un monde idéal parce
que j'aime bien vraiment que le monde
soit vidéo et les bonnes raisons petit
sapiens s'épanouit en cinq étapes
d'une part il ya deux personnes dans le
clan qui prennent spécifiquement soin de
lui et qui l'entourent de leur amour ça
c'est ses parents c'est grâce à ça il va
comprendre qu' il est aimable et qu' il
peut avoir confiance en l'autre et
toutes les relations qui va vivre à
partir de celle là faut être basée sur
cette confiance et cette relation
ensuite il va apprendre parce que ses
parents font le pousser à se débrouiller
seul il va apprendre l'autonomie et va
en retenir qu'il peut avoir confiance en
lui il sait faire le clan valve fait le
féliciter chaque fois qu'il réussit à un
truc difficile qui fait son premier feu
qui cueille son premier fruit et de ça
il retient que il a de la valeur il a de
l'estimé pour lui le clan est à l'affût
de tous les cygnes d'information à leur
petit sapiens on lui propose d'abord
d'exprimer tout ce qu'il ressent et puis
une fois qu'on aura mille langage au
point de dire tout ce qu'ils pensent de
là il apprend que en fait il est libre
de s'exprimer et enfin le clan édicte
des règles parce que dans la vie sauvage
on ne survit pas n'importe comment il
faut faire gaffe et de sa petite soeur
piaf apprend qu'il ya des limites à ce
qui peut faire et au final on a un petit
sapiens qui est grosse un gros capital
confiance personnelle par mimétisme il
interagit avec tout le monde il envoie
des signes positifs de reconnaissance
avec une haute valeur énergétique et le
clan il est super demandeurs parce que
ça augmente l'énergie général et en plus
mieux les gens collaborent plus le clan
a des chances de survivre dans ce monde
idéal
tout le monde est épanouie et tout le
monde est libre d'être lui-même voire
excellents alors voilà j'étais pas homo
sapiens en tout cas pas à l'époque je le
suis juste maintenant et personne ne
serait vraiment jamais ce qui se passait
à cette époque là j'aurais donc pu
prendre maintenant
avant de prendre maintenant comme
exemple j'ai quatre petites questions
trois quatre questions à vous poser est
ce que vous connaissez des gens qui se
trouvent moches nul il intéressant pas
utile parce que vous connaissez des gens
dont on sait jamais ce qu'ils pensent
vraiment ou qu'ils n'expriment pas leur
émotion
est ce que vous connaissez des gens qui
doutent de même un point que même il
faut parfois les rassurer un peu tout le
temps
ben ces gens ils ont juste pas eu la
chance de petits sapiens pire ils vivent
le paradoxe du rejet par peur d'être
rejeté ils ont rejeté eux mêmes des
partis d'eux-mêmes comme ça ils sont pas
jugés ils sont pas mal
chez ces gens là chez ces gens là on ne
parle plus de soif de reconnaissance
on parle de manque de reconnaissance
parce que ces partis qui leur manque
c'est parti qu'ils ont projeté elle leur
manque là plusieurs raisons possibles à
sa la première ça pose la famille dans
la famille on a tous un rôle on est
l'aîné on est le cas d'e on et l'intello
on est le manuel le chouchou lectra
terrestre c'est un rôle et dans ce rôle
là peut-être on peut pas exprimer qui en
est vraiment fallu une tête de l'école
sympa l'école un beau moule dans lequel
l'on doit rentrer et pour qu'on me rende
bien on nous indique toutes nos erreurs
en rouge ça c'est la partie de gauche
pour le même prix on nous indique tout
ce qu'on sait faire envers fait juste
meilleur pour l'estimé de soi des
enfants
ça peut venir aussi de la société
actuelle avec ses modèles et ses modèles
qui nous font penser que tout compte
fait je suis trop gros je reviens de
faire du sport si j'achète pas le
dernier smartphone je passais pour un
naze
il ya plein d'autres possibilités mais
je voulais juste attirer votre attention
sur le fait que le regard qu'on porte
sur les gens et nos attentes ont un
poids ils ont un pouvoir sur eux ils
peuvent entamer leur belle leur beau
capital le capital confiance personnelle
chaque mode et valorisant chaque
remarque chaque critique
chaque geste de rejet a un impact sur
les gens qui le reçoivent c'est
peut-être après bach ils vont plus aux
émaux montrer tout ce qu'ils sont ils
vont perdre confiance en eux ils vont se
trouver nulle
c'est ça être comme il faut non sans
blague
alors voilà personne n'est responsable
des partis qui l'a enlevée de lui pour
être acceptée mais il nous appartient
maintenant d'en prendre soin comme
disait jean paul sartre tu n'es pas
responsable de ce qu'on a fait de toi
mais tu es responsable de ce que tu fais
de ce qu'on a fait de toi alors voilà
l'heure est venue de reconnaître nos
qualités d'êtres humains et non qualité
tout court plus pour ça je suis coach
moi je fais bosser les gens la meilleure
façon c'est une petite expérience
donc je vais vous proposer si les moyens
d'allumer la salle de seconde
je vais proposer à toutes les personnes
en bout de rangée de se tourner vers le
roi than droite ou leur voisine de
droite est de former des pères comme ça
jusqu'au bout déranger je vous en prie
si jamais en bout de rangée vous vous
trouvez tout seul
bah vous pouvez faire une paire avec la
personne devant ou derrière vous ok vous
y êtes
la consigne il va être très simple
attendez que j'ai fini avant de vous
lancer j'invite toutes les personnes de
gauche à faire un compliment à la
personne de droite et toutes les
personnes de droite ont droit et
l'obligation mais en droit à un seul et
unique mot merci je vous en prie
ça va parfait
c'était la première partie de
l'expérience la deuxième partie elle
s'appelle réciproque on gèle invite les
personnes qui viennent de recevoir un
compliment à faire un compliment à la
personne qui vient de randonnée avec la
même consigne la personne qui le reçoit
cette fois ci a droit à un seul et
unique mot merci deuxième rang
vous y êtes super alors maintenant je
vous invite simplement si vous avez
trouvé cette expérience confortable à
lever la main qui a trouvé cette
expérience confortable
super ça c'est top c'est même carrément
encourageants qui a trouvé cette
expérience confrontant tu lever la main
également
ça fait plaisir merci pour votre courage
et ça fait vraiment plaisir
super et j'ai juste deux questions à
vous poser
suis-je habitués enfin que j'aimerais
vous vous posiez suis habitué à donner
et à recevoir des signes de
reconnaissance positif quel effet ça me
fait on va aller un cran plus loin et je
vais vous inviter à prendre contact avec
les parties de vous même que vous avez
acheté au fil du temps et pour ça on va
faire super simple on va prendre un
modèle c'est ce qui marche le mieux
donc j'ai vous inviter à deviner la
personne dont je vous parle
elle a les qualités suivantes les a les
qualités pour y continuer sans mais elle
a les qualités suivantes
c'est quelqu'un qui a confiance en lui
et qui est autonome voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui essaye les choses qui
l'intéressent et quand ça marche pas qui
se relève assez vite
c'est quelqu'un qui est proche de ses
émotions qui les expriment facilement
car ils les écoutent
c'est quelqu'un qui sait dire non mais
qui poursuit son chemin qu'est qui a
toutes les compétences dont vous vous
visualisez cette personne
quand je fais l'exercice avec mes
coaches et je leur répond ceci cette
personne c'est toi à deux ans
alors voilà toutes les parties que nous
avons refoulé auto au cours du temps
elles sont là en nous pour les
réapprivoiser faut simplement changer le
regard que nous avons sur nous-mêmes et
pour sa dernière question pour la route
je vais vous inviter à vous rappeler qui
était le héros de votre enfance
la personne ou le personnage à qui vous
aviez vraiment envie de ressembler et
quelle était sa principale valeur sa
compétence sa qualité
vous vous rappelez à partir
d'aujourd'hui je vous inviter à changer
les choses à vous réapproprier tout
votre être en entier pour être acteur de
vos vies et pas acteur à mi-temps ou
demi acteurs de l'ombre acteurs de vos
vies ça commence ici et maintenant et ça
commence par quelques phrases simples
je vous invite à tous vous dire j'ai ma
place ici je peux m'exprimer ce que je
pense et ce que je sens j'ai confiance
en moi je suis autonome et j'ai de la
valeur j'ai des qualités et la première
d'entre elles si jamais vous avez besoin
d'un socle pour vous lancer la première
d'entre elles c'est celle que vous avez
reconnu chez le héros de votre enfance
à partir du moment où vous l'avez vu
chez lui merci
[Applaudissements]